all right go for it
Oh what did you party people welcome to
another episode of real mature it's a
show that we make about things you do
when you grow up and one of the things
that happens to you when you grow up is
the way you party changes so we have
three different stories about well
partying the first one involves Keith oh
let's do this Hannah me let's get it
let's go
goes go all right all right later camera
so today's episode is about the way you
party and how it changes as you get
older so the first piece is by Keith yes
so I'm for an experiment me and my two
friends were about 29 and 30 went back
to my college to try and party like we
did when we were 20 21 etc it took us
less than 20 seconds to get stopped by
the police my name is Brian Wolfe
I am a handsome 30 year old man some
Keith I'm a beautiful 27 year old boy
I'm Marc Mezvinsky I'm 29 looking fine
and I am back at my alma mater
to party like we used to see if we can
do it see if it's still fun so we're
gonna go pick up Marc Marc I met in
college
so he's gonna get in the car and he's
gonna tell you about his whole
experience Marc you go take a seat bye
Henry
alright are you guys ready to watch this
yeah let's do it
alright so we used to drink like many
college students are fond of and we used
to play a game called scepter or I've
heard it's also called Wizards staff
scepter where you would tape the next
beer to the top of the one you just
finished and so as you drank you'd
slowly get a longer and longer scepter
and I am what I think is colloquially
known as a whim never got one that was
more than probably seven was my max I
like how you feel bad about having only
drank out seven beers so I think tonight
you know because now I'm older and wiser
and can think more strategically I think
I can get to eight can just say for the
record this is
stupid go there Paul stupid Henry none
of them are gonna impress you five years
five this scepter has five so around
five I was wandering around the party
doing dramatic what in my brain I
assumed was GoPro party cinematography
so what do you look for in a party
companion uh someone who is rocking it
just our design who's this guy
this is his name is Brian but his
nickname amongst his college friends is
stick I mean he looks glorious yeah he
was he's an awesome guy the thing that
makes me think of as like a 32 year old
it's just like I don't party with anyone
like like stick yeah I was able to get
to eight years which is the I guess my
new record look how happy you are with
your chapter that was thrilled so thanks
for the swing by memory lane oh no did
going back and partying like you did ten
years ago
make you wish you were still 10 years
younger um it made me glad I did it once
but it actually just made me thrilled
that I'm not although those parties are
fun when you're done with that lifestyle
and you go out into a bigger more adult
world all the rewards for everything you
do during the day gets so much bigger
that that stuff is just as fun as
partying it's very grown-up the next
video was a video that I pretty much
thrust upon our intern Kane and two of
our other interns I brought them into a
meeting they didn't know what was going
to happen and I said in seven hours you
are going to have a dinner party ready
at one of your guys houses for three of
the senior producers on our team we have
no idea what we're gonna do yet I'm on
Pintrest
Oh - hey going with a California ish
theme yeah the theme is is fresh it's
been two hours at Trader Joe's day four
so now as a Trader Joe's okay so after
buying like the most random assortment
of things at Target like can anyone tell
me like which one is a serving tray I'm
on my way to Kane's house and we're
gonna do this thing all right we're
starting to cook now we have all our
stuff ready we move the table down I
think we start off slow we did take a
20-minute nap earlier because we were
telling her I honestly think things have
been going pretty smoothly like I feel
like we divvied up everything pretty
equally and like we backed along really
well
oh my god we can use this tried a new
recipe that I'm not used to I should do
that
you suppose be cleaning it I got it yeah
why not oh maybe not
wait what
everyone's gonna get drunk just kidding
everything right now
you know wage behind you behind that
door right there yeah a dinner party
thrown by interns them just trying is
probably enough but we'll see I don't
know maybe it'll be a disaster yeah I'm
curious what we're gonna talk about you
know what like what do the interns have
to say guys feel free to grab a seat
we made some Moscow meals for you oh
great oh [ __ ] the fire still on so what
are these things here these are mini
quiches yes and they are made of spinach
and artichoke and Parmesan and tonsure
mozzarella is there a casa uh that's
like a gift that's the name yeah that
means gonna crush their like they are
crustless so this is salad I'm trying to
get the rest of the food together so
that you know when it's time for dinner
could happen seamlessly and they don't
have to wait you know Henry's a tough
one how did you go I think it's going
well I mean it's gotta get the combo
flowing a little bit once they finish
those Moscow meals I think everyone will
be okay this is our big finish we have
the salmon and the rice and then the
vegetables it's amazing
you guys are be too polite but thank you
you think of the salmon guys great photo
of you was like nice and set off a lot
of work I am so proud of these I've
never used a little like pastry frosting
thing before like my friend Heidi over
sometimes like yeah yeah yeah Sofia me
this was lovely we have and then we have
a fun game okay I mean you're feeling it
you're feeling drinks right yeah you're
definitely feeling it
whenever like four more courses and I
thought like I thought it was just he
should have been like yeah good job kids
good job guys but no it just kept going
and that's what was great about the
vibes are good the food was good and it
was just all about having good timing
being together I can't believe this is
your first time doing this thank you so
much yeah you guys I think there was a
moment when it was like close to the
time when people were coming and we were
just all in the kitchen like and my eggs
burned the eggs and the onions burning
was pains like Lois like actually pour
it all out redo the race it was a
pleasant evening
I feel like that's such an adult thing
to say so that was a great video um I
think we should go see Bo and find out
how his experience yeah let's head to
that place where that guy died in his
yard what it's if you can catch it in
frozen pizza party tour 2k15 What's Up B
whoa
all right so we are going to watch your
experience now of what it was like going
back to party like you did 10 years ago
okay my goal for tonight is to try and
take over the party I'm going to try and
get people to do activities to join me
and just make the whole event about me
ah
you care what the costumes thought of
you as your party I wanted to have the
most fun possible and generally having
the most fun possible is getting as many
people together to share that fun I'm
all right
I haven't had my coffee yet who's this
bearded man in the background I was
wondering when you guys would notice the
naked man in the bed yeah is that the
first time you found him I was able to
achieve my goals just about got
everybody to chance some things able
sing some songs at the party got dance
party going so that was good I'm staying
still in college yeah if you party in
here yeah into it yeah nice you stand
great that's cool you stay maybe wait
wait is that stick back Nick we love
stick you know stick is like this super
party bro but he's also the sweetest man
at that she looks like Zac Efron in
neighbors I got the Maui wowie which has
jalapenos ham cheese and I had such a
great time eating that food it's
fabulous very real but this morning I am
feeling that food how did you feel idea
tonight successful I felt incredibly
successful at this point we've outlasted
most of the actual college series yeah
that's great you guys outlasted the
college students yeah do you want to
party like this more now that you've had
a taste of it absolutely not
uh no no all right we'll go on to the
next segment uh who here knows who
Andrew W K is I do any W K is a rock
musician these terms of into the world's
foremost authority on partying we also
like he's almost has like a philosophy
of partying so we asked our friend
comedian Greg Barris to interview them
at the everything is festival in
Portland a couple weeks ago and find out
some of his amazing rules for partying
hey it's great Barris for BuzzFeed you
know from the internet talking with
Andrew W K about partying as an adult
hello how are you I'm doing good how you
doing fine thank you how did you become
an expert on partying well by doing it
primarily by engaging in a celebratory
mindset but primarily you can declare
yourself to take on an endeavor so I
said I want to be good at partying and
so all what would be hold I was why did
you pick partying to get cheered up
obviously you were unshared I struggle
with that consistently definitely wanted
to cheer myself up this partying mindset
has helped with that a great deal and
it's been the motivation for my life
mission so it kills I don't wanna say
kill super it flutters two birds with
one gust of wind that is beautiful thank
you am I too old party well no I would
so I say someone would be too old if
there's parts of their physique which is
grown decrepid but even then partying
can actually help bolster the body if
you're 99 years old and your body has
grown decrepit and and withered for
example there was a gentleman on the
airplane today they had two crutches he
was quite elderly but he was still Hardy
in spirit so his his partying may be
less physical and more secure
based and then someone like a young
child who is only scampering and whose
soul hasn't developed that much yet
because that if they haven't lived that
long at least in this embodiment maybe
their there are more physical parties
you know they're just running them up so
like I'm in my 30s I get tired easily I
can't party like the way I used to like
water like some ways to combat party
fatigue well actually being fatigued it
can count as partying oh so resting okay
sitting like you're doing now laying
napping napping but nap hard for people
with like a more conventional lifestyle
like a day job how do they integrate
partying into like that lifestyle you
have usually eight hours of work
hopefully that you can take some kind of
pride in even if you hate the job can
still try to do a good job of what you
hate eight hours of rest yeah you know
or some version of that and then you
hope to have eight hours to kind of do
whatever else and that's the precious
time so really that if you only have
that precious eight hours of your life
you can make that count and really
really sort of live in that slice pet
food or something for something - you
always are some yeah it's more something
all the time
weird that's pretty cool yeah pretty
good so are you ready to watch your
party experience sure I edited it so I
know what it is let's watch it okay one
of the objectives I have is to play beer
pong and win a game of beer pong I will
have to play beer pong until I win
because I used to win
I haven't played beer pong in a long
time we're doing it
girl montage are you embarrassed by how
important beer pong is to you I used to
win beer pong all the time I built my
own beer pong table it was called the
floorboard because I made it out of
flooring oh well we did it we got back
at 4 or 3:45 it was crazy night we
played played beer pong las first game
me and B will really embraced the true
nature of beer pong which is to say
something together with your partner
every time you're about to shoot so now
I'll get you in the zone for us to win
we had to go octa various so nefarious
and it's also about the power of touch
entering the unites people me and Mark
tried to chug a beer faster than a girl
I couldn't both college students beat
both of us and the chugging contest mark
didn't even try where I just didn't try
we went to Foursquare through the
Foursquare I fell down to look up there
it's funny how often you get hurt while
drinking when you're young versus now
like I never been hurt
yeah because when you're young and
drinking you have so much more energy to
like go out and attack the world where
now if I'm drinking I'm like I'm cool to
sit on the stool yeah I don't feel
invincible
anywhere but today we're pretty hungover
we're gonna go eat some shepherd's pie
at an Irish pub that's it right we do it
yeah so now we're getting tacos at my
favorite taco stand did anything about
this experience make you guys sad the
thing that I missed the most about
college is the immediacy of all your
friends how easy it is for 25 people
that you really love to just show up in
ten minutes so that's pretty much it you
know we went down we all had pretty much
the same time we had a lot of fun but
ultimately we like partying how we
already party here which really is is
similar we get drunk we just don't stay
out as late and we don't drink to like
incredible excess anymore of yep we
found the highlights of what this can be
and then we do those to the best of our
ability and that's how you party as you
get older I guess plus [ __ ] tacos for
days yeah I talk a little day goes for
day so with that thanks for watching
real mature so next time what to do what
it do what to do